all right everybody here it is the new
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania we've been waiting for it so
let's not waste any time let's dive in I
hope we see a lot of Kang
you're an interesting man
Scotland
[Applause]
[Music]
you have a daughter
just like the plot League said of course
lost a lot of time we could help each
other with that
was offering him it seems like
who are you come on give me a good look
at him I'm the man who can give you the
one thing you want
yo what's that oh time it's so cool how
he does look blue and okay that's
awesome
I can rewrite existence rewrite
existence and shatter timelines
yo you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much he looks
amazing
Second Chance oh because it's a snap
because she was because he lost that
time it was five years now okay he wants
that time back from Cassie
let me make this easy for you
you're telling me what I need oh they're
like actual ants everything you call it
maybe they wear it
it's all my fault
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
no
modak
I thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
sorry Cassie
oh he looks amazing
oh my gosh
is that it yo
Kang looks amazing oh hold on bring me
back bring me back to that part
wow
okay I I was excited before
I am even more excited now Kang looks
amazing the movie as a whole
looks crazy good insanely good
this just wow okay I think this is you
know
I think this is the best way to start
off base five the big bad of the entire
Multiverse Saga going up against Ant-Man
who we love and a lot of ant-mans we
knew there were going to be a lot of
variants but wow they looked like actual
ants there were so many variants so this
is gonna be pretty crazy this will be
pretty crazy maybe you can multiply
himself because we saw him kind of split
so maybe it's like the same
Consciousness who knows
but I'm here for this movie I'm super
excited gonna get started on the
breakdown right now but let me know how
excited you are for this film in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe and of course
you know always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter I'll see you guys in the
next video